researchers have confirmed
100 bull shark attacks
[Music]
but the real number may be much higher
because the bull shark is so difficult
to identify
when you first look at a bull shark it
doesn't really jump out at you that it's
a bull shark it just kind of looks like
other sharks yeah kind of grayish brown
on top white below
that's really different from an iconic
species like the tiger shark that has
that really square head
and those stripes that set it apart from
any other species
then you also have white sharks nobody's
gonna mistake a white shark
this is a really iconic look you have
the torpedo
shape the tail the bright white belly
slate gray above
the bull shark's looks aren't showy or
iconic
but if you know what to look for you'll
never forget it
when you really start to look closer at
the bull sharks you see some features
that differ from
typical shark shape they
almost look like swimming mounds in time
they're really thick
from those pectoral fins forward you
know huge jaws
and then they've got the musculature to
back that up
[Music]
you